here it's been in terms of the castings
who has been the actor who most
resembles either physically or in terms
of the way they have inhabited the role
the way you had it in your head
probably Peter Dinklage's as Tyrion not
that there aren't differences I mean if
you if you carefully read the
descriptions in the book Tyrion in the
books is is actually shorter than Peter
Dinklage so probably the first time
Peters been told he's tall for a role
but that yeah he is he is taller than
Tyrion in the books and he's
considerably better looking I mean
there's the books make a certain amount
of comment on the fact that dead Tyrion
is not attractive shell conventional
standards and as that that crossed the
bear in addition to his height but but
you know Peter is uh is quite a
good-looking man and nonetheless with
these tiny exceptions he he is Tyrion I
mean he has thoroughly inhabited that
role and he was really the only person I
mean at that very first meeting I had
with David Mann after we discussed all
the story stuff we got into playing the
casting game and yeah we would like who
would be good who could we get this
person and could we look at that person
and when we got to Tyrion it was it was
Peter Dinklage there was no one we never
read anyone else for that role we've
never had meetings with anyone else for
that role when we got the green light we
just went out and made an offer to Peter
Dinklage and thankfully he accepted and
you know here we are and an Emmy and a
Golden Globe later yeah and the scream
Awards never forget that when his head
came out of a giant who were that was
that memorable so he was great Sean Bean
it's another yeah character we did read
some other people for the role of Ned
which was crucial but Sean Bean was
always our first choice there and
thankfully we were able to get him - and
do you find now that as you're writing
that when you see the characters in your
mind's eye you're seeing the characters
in the TV show the geography you see
seeing it with the locations that
they've used in the TV show I think I
understand that process and I know that
that that has probably already happened
for many many millions of viewers and
fans but I don't think it happens if you
really know a book then you have your
own images in your head and seeing a
movie or a TV show doesn't doesn't just
place them I mean a book like Tolkien's
Lord of rings which I've first read when
I was 13 years old I've written many
many times I love Peter Jackson's movies
make no mistake those are terrific
movies but when I sit down to read
Fellowship of the Ring as I as I still
do every few years because I love the
book so much Strider does not look like
Viggo Mortensen to me yeah he looks like
the image I've had in my head of Strider
since he was 13 mmm and the hobbits
don't look like you know Elijah Wood and
and Sean Astin and all that of those
they were great mind you they did a
wonderful job but my own images are too
firmly rooted and yeah that's true for
Tolkien it's certainly true from my own
books so you know the roots go very deep
there but for someone who isn't me I can
easily see that happening and and the
actors likenesses becoming what you
think of when you when you think of this
particular character the famous saying
which I don't necessarily agree with
that everyone has a book in side of them
of course you've written since such a
young agent such a variety of things do
you think that Song of Ice and Fire is
is the book that you've always had it or
the story that you've always had inside
of you or is it just a story in your
canon well I don't think there's any
doubt now that it's my magnum opus it's
the biggest thing I've ever done it's
the most ambitious thing I've ever done
and you know I I don't I mean I I hope
that I will finish these last two books
and complete this series strongly and
then I will live another 20 30 years and
write many more things many different
things in the in the years to come but I
don't think I will ever again attempt
anything on this scale I mean it's it's
daunting it's I began this in 1991 so
and did you know the scale of it at that
point not know it it grew it grew in
various stages but I'm certainly trying
to do it in seven nine seven and seven
would be great it's it's you know seven
gods seven kingdoms seven books there's
a there's a certain elegance to that
that I would like to retain but that
being said the main thing is to tell the
story beginning middle and end not to
rush the story or to squeeze things or
to do that but what to do the whole
thing because it really is no matter how
many books you divide it up into three
books or five books or seven books
whatever it's one story hmm one very
complex story with a lot of viewpoint
characters and interweaving but still
one story
hmm if you had to say it was any one
person's story it's not know know who
which current did you see most of
yourself in you know what the viewpoint
characters have elements of me in them I
think that's the only way you can really
write a viewpoint character as you get
inside someone's skin and and all that
it's the not one you'd love the most
though well I've always had a great deal
of affection for Tyrion mm-hmm like
Tyrion is probably who I would like to
be and Sam is probably closer to who I
actually am I'm not nearly as wittiest
here Ian
well actually I am as wittiest here
Ian's as I invent all of his witty
things but it takes me ages to to invent
all those yeah all the tough
like three days later I'm sure I'll do
this when I watch this interview on
throne castle god I should have said
that there that would have been really
funny and Tyrion of course would think
of it right away and the Matilda that
tossed off those comments